Tu devrais lui donner un vrai aspirateur, peut-être tu gagnerais du temps sur le ménage
Oui, bah on a déjà essayé et elle préfère les faux
Attends, t'es stressée qu'est ce qui t'arrives là?
Ouais je suis stressée... On repeint la chambre d'Emma cette après-midi
et la peinture c'est hyper nocif pour les bébé, je sais pas
et la peinture c'est hyper nocif pour les bébés
Je sais pas à qui la confier, j'ai personne !
Attend Julie
Je suis ton frère j'ai 29 ans et on commence un peu a se connaître
Peut-etre que tu peux me la confier non?
Quoi t'es sérieux là ? Tu veux que je te confie mon enfant. Alors que tes deux poisson rouge son mort parce que tu leurs donnait pas a manger.
Alors déjà, excuse moi mais la nourriture pour poisson c'est extrêmement dur a trouver.
Et en plus sur les deux poissons y'en a un seul qui est mort.
Starsky il vas très bien
Allez Emma, Vien avec tonton un petit peu.
Tu l'aimes bien tonton ?
Regarde on dirait pas un super tonton ?
Alors tu me l'a confie ou pas ?
OK
Yes !!!
Yes ..
Yea
Être adulte c'est parfois être responsable de quelqu'un.
Quesque c'est que ça ?
Hé bah ca c'est des couches, c'est pour une pote.
Soit ta pote elle est très jeune soit elle est très vielle .
Ah Cyprien, c'est vrai que t'habite là toi aussi.
Ah c'est vrai que j'habite chez moi .
Norman je t`'ai tout noté là
Si il y'a le moindre problème
je t'appel
Tu m'appel
Ok bon on n'a tout la poussette est devant l'entrée.
C'est bon
Tu oublies de me donner ..
Bisous mon amour.
Allez Emma tu viens avec tonton.
Voila comme ça  avec tonton.
Allez chao!
Emma
J'adore les momes
t'a pas de momes norman..
Enfin, j'adore les momes des autres quoi.
Ouais.. Non Oublie cette phrase. C'étais chelou c'étais pas ce que je voulais dire.
Mec, ça sens pas la sauce pour les nems
N'importe quoi.
*Rire d'Emma*
Ah Ouais.
Ah, Merde heu, aller on va allez jouer au échec
D'accord.
Ou on fait un sudoku ou un scrabble, comme tu veux.
Tu vas voir Emma.
Celui si aspire vraiment ! tu vas adorer !
Hop! Et c'est parti ! Regarde on aspire la poussière !
Non, Non, Non ! Ne pleure pas regarde
J'aspire la.. la.. Clé USB De Cyprien
On N’arrête tout ! C'étais la pire idée du monde !
On fais quoi on vas se promener.
Tu vois c'est bien la promenade
Super dans un magasin. Bonne idée
Je suis deg le clavier il est péter la touche E ne marche plus quoi.
Bah écrie des phrases sans la lettre E
Putain. C'est encore pire que le W ou un truc comme sa..
Il est ou le rayon informatique ?
Je sais pas.
Ça me soûle de leur devoir acheter toute clavier juste pour la touche E.
Peut-être que tu peux acheter que la touche E.
En tout cas elle pleure plus. Elle fait plus aucun bruit.
Heu.. Norman, elle est plus là..
Emma ! Emma !  Emma ! Emma !
Emma ! T'es où !? Emma ! Emma !
Tonton est là !
Ok, je vais voir a l’accueil !
*Dame qui parle*
Excuser-moi désoler désoler, c'est pour une urgence.
On n'a perdu un enfant dans le magasin
Ah pas de problème on va faire une annonce. Alors comment elle s'appelle ?
Les vêtement ?
C'est une fille.
Nous recherchons une petite fille qui n'a pas de prénom.
Et qui...
sent..
Fentirelle la sauce pour les nems.
Nous l'attendons a l’accueil du magasin.
c'est bon pour Starsky sa.
Des touches de clavier a limité ?
Je l'ai pas trouver !
Bon ou est qu'une enfant de trois ans irais ?
Bah déjà pas dans un magasin de bricolage c'est sur !
Bon sinon pour le rayon informatique c'est au fond a droite après le micro-ondes et les aspirateurs
Tu vas où !
Bah Julie ça va ? Bon voila j'ai un truc a te dire.. c'est un détail mais..
Mais Emma a disparu. Sinon ça va sa avance les peintures tout ça ?
Allo Julie.. Heum.. Bon j'ai un truc a te dire.
Non, C'est moi qui a un truc a te dire Norman. Je suis désolée.
J'ai douté de toi, alors que t'es mon frère, t'es la personne en qui je peux avoir le plus confiance.
Et puis je suis certaine que tu t'occupe hyper bien d'Emma.
Sa me touche. Ouais t'a raison je fais plutôt bien mon rôle de petit frère
c'est clair.
Elle est où là elle fait quoi ? Elle va bien ?
Bah ouais elle va bien a mon avis.
A ton avis ? De quoi a ton avis ? Elle est où là ?!
Passe-moi là.
Heu..Je te rappelle ! Très belle aspirateur. Surtout tu dis pas à maman que je t'ai perdu
Ok !
Tu le dis pas.. Maman ! Voila exactement !
Maman ! Maman ! Maman !
Yes
Ça va ? Ouais Ouais
Quesque vous faites là ? Pourquoi t'es tout blanc ?
Bah je sais pas c'est ma couleur naturel.
Ta couleur naturelle
On rentre à la maison mon doudou ?
Vous venez là ?
Yes !
(Musique)
Sky est tout seul car son coéquipier est mort !
Bon j'y vais Merci Chao!
Bisou
*Reniflement*
De la sauce pour les nems.
N'importe quoi.
Merci d'avoir écouter abonner vous a Norman ! Clique sur sa tête pour t'abonner a lui ! :)) Norman le meilleur Youtubeur de youtube !
:)